estamos en el problema 32 cuál es la
solución a esta ecuación que es uno más
1 / x cuadrada igual a 3 / x y realmente
esta ecuación parece bastante aterradora
porque tenemos x cuadrada si x en el
denominador pero más saber que si
simplificamos mucho esta expresión vamos
a llegar algo que al menos conocemos
cómo resolver y lo primero que se me
ocurre además de copiar exactamente la
misma ecuación se me ocurre que podemos
multiplicar de ambos lados por x
cuadrada digamos multiplicamos todo esto
por x cuadrada y también todo esto por x
cuadrada que es lo que estoy ganando que
al menos en el denominador van a
desaparecer las x cuadradas y que es lo
que me queda me queda x cuadrada x 1 es
x cuadrada más x cuadrada x 1 / x
cuadrada pues eso es simplemente una
verdad para eso lo hice y ahora del otro
lado me queda 3 entre x x x cuadrada
esto es
x ahora sí pasamos el 3x del lado
izquierdo restando nos queda x cuadrada
menos 3x más uno es igual a cero y como
ves este problema que en principio
parecía bastante complicado ahora
simplemente llegamos a una ecuación
cuadrática verdad a una a una ecuación
de segundo grado muy bien entonces esto
no parece que se pueda factorizar no
porque digamos que dos números que
multiplicados me den uno pues pues
debería ser 1 y 1 verdad o menos 1 y
menos 1 y no nos da menos 3 la suma así
que vamos a tener que usar la fórmula
cuadrática que nos dice la fórmula
cuadrática que las soluciones están
dadas por menos b pero aquí b es todo
este menos 3 así que si yo quiero menos
b va a ser menos menos tres que es tres
y sumamos bueno tenemos más menos la
raíz de b cuadrada que es menos 3 al
cuadrado es 9 menos 4 a porsche pero a
es
se es 14 por a porsche es 4 simplemente
y todo esto lo dividimos entre 2 a 0 a
es 1 entonces esto es 2 muy bien
entonces esto solo para separarlo
tenemos tres medios más menos la raíz de
9 menos 45 sobre 2 muy bien entonces
nuestras dos soluciones están dadas
justamente por tres medios más la raíz
de 5 sobre 2 y también por tres medios
menos la raíz de 5 sobre 2 ahí está
escrito en la solución de los problemas
que tengo aquí aparte
vamos con el siguiente vamos con el
ejercicio 33 dice hay dos números dos
números con las siguientes propiedades
el segundo número es tres más que el
primero entonces el segundo número es el
primero más tres bienestar es más que el
primero ahora bien segunda propiedad el
producto de ambos números es nada más
que su suma entonces el primero por el
segundo es igual a nueve más que es la
suma es decir nueve más que p más
ese muy bien muy bien entonces ya
tenemos dos ecuaciones dos incógnitas
vamos a tratar de resolverlo y cómo
vamos a hacerlo pues lo primero que se
me ocurre es hacer una sustitución
tenemos que s&p más tres podemos
sustituirlo aquí entonces tenemos pe que
multiplica a ese pero ese es
p 33 y esto debe ser igual a 9 más p más
s pero s nuevamente es p más 3 ok
entonces ya con esto vamos a desarrollar
vamos a desarrollar y p x p esp cuadrada
más 3 x ps3p acá de este lado podemos
agrupar este 9 y este 3 y nos da 12 y p
más peso 2 p el 2 p digamos restamos 2p
de ambos lados se cancela aquí y me
queda t cuadrada más 3 p - 2 p
simplemente me queda una p es igual a 12
y que si pasamos ahora el 12 restando
del lado izquierdo
tenemos p cuadrada más p - 12 es igual a
cero nuevamente llegamos a una ecuación
cuadrática verdad entonces esto sí se ve
como que podemos factorizar lo
los que multiplicados me den menos 12 y
suma 21 por ejemplo puede ser menos
cuatro con
33 entonces menos 4 por 3 es menos 12
menos 43
ok quizás debemos cambiar el signo le
cambiamos el signo para nada ahora estés
y ahora sí 4 x menos 3 es menos 12
perdón y 4 menos tres es uno muy bien
entonces al factorizar lo obtenemos esto
y esto sigue siendo igual a cero
entonces tengo un producto que es igual
a cero que es lo que obtenemos que p es
igual a menos 4 verdad simplemente de
que este primer factor es cero
si esto es 0 p es menos 4 o bien este
factor es cero y eso quiere decir que p
- 3 es cero y lo que implica que p tiene
que ser 3 entonces mi primer número o es
menos 4 o estrés vamos a regresar nos de
este lado si p es igual
a menos 4 cuánto vale s s vale menos 43
que es menos 1 por otro lado si p vale 3
cuánto vale s pues y ps3 ese estrés más
3 que es 6 entonces dentro de las
opciones que nos da la página de donde
estoy sacando esto es la opción b es
está muy bien
entonces vamos con el siguiente vídeo el
perdón con el siguiente ejercicio laura
está resolviendo la ecuación x cuadrada
menos 8 x igual a 9 completando el
binomio cuadrado que el número debería
sumarse de ambos lados de la ecuación
para completar el cuadrado entonces
además de que ya me estaba saltando otro
vídeos vamos a tratar de resolver este
ejercicio no sé dónde tengo la cabeza
pero bueno a ver entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es sumar algo de ambos lados
para que podamos completar el binomio
para que se se se complete el binomio
cuadrado perfecto verdad entonces vamos
a escribirlo esto es x cuadrada menos 8x
y voy a dejar un espacio para sumar algo
y esto debe ser igual a 9 entonces
sabemos que tenemos que sumar algo para
que este trinomio perdón deberías decir
siempre trinomio sea un cuadrado
perfecto debo sumar algo entonces
esencialmente es un número
que sumado consigo mismo me de menos 8 y
entonces lo que vamos a agregar aquí es
su cuadrado verdad tengo que pensar en
un número que sumado consigo mismo 9
menos 8 y entonces sumar e aquí el
cuadrado de ese número entonces quien
sumando consigo mismo es menos 8 pues es
menos 4 verdad y si sumamos el cuadrado
de eso eso sería sumar 16 entonces
sumamos 16 de ambos lados y de esto me
queda que esto es x menos cuatro verdad
el número que dijimos al cuadrado y esto
sería 25 muy bien entonces en realidad
el número que siempre hay que sumar es
el cuadrado de esto a la mitad verdad
menos 8 entre 2 es menos 4 al cuadrado
es 16 y en realidad no nos pidieron
resolver solo nos preguntaron cuánto
había que sumar y aquí ya está hay que
sumarle 16 y que aquí es la respuesta b
ok entonces es simplemente que es lo que
tenemos que hacer tenemos
una propuesta para hacer trinomio
cuadrado perfecto hay que sumarle la
mitad de este número al cuadrado verdad
y la mitad de este fue menos 4 al
cuadrado es 16 muy bien entonces de ahí
de ahí de hecho es de donde viene la
ecuación cuadrática verdad simplemente
de completar el trinomio cuadrado
perfecto
vamos con el último ejercicio de este
vídeo cuál de las siguientes describe de
forma más precisa la traslación de la
gráfica de igual a x + 3 al cuadrado
menos 2 a la gráfica de ye igual a x2 al
cuadrado más 2 ok y lo más fácil de ver
siempre es el desplazamiento en la
coordenada y déjenme hacer
más o menos ahí están mis ejes x y este
es mi eje y y lo que tenemos es piensen
por ejemplo en la en la ecuación de x
cuadrada
entonces más o menos se ve como una
parábola así verdad entonces quién sería
igual a equis
cuadrada + 2 pues en 0 ahora va a valer
2 simplemente estamos trasladando dos
unidades hacia arriba verdad
bien entonces ahí está mi nueva parábola
y piensen también en la equis cuadrada
menos
déjeme déjenme quitar esto de aquí
y no le hagan tanto caso a esto y mejor
lo ponemos junto a su gráfica esta es
igual a equis cuadrada más 2 donde
pondrían ustedes la gráfica de yegua la
equis cuadrada menos 2 pues sería
trasladar hacia aquí abajo
donde cruza en -2 esta es igual a equis
cuadrada menos 2 entonces realmente
pueden pensarlo de esa forma tenemos
algo al cuadrado menos 2 que
correspondería más o menos algo así y
nos movemos a algo al cuadrado más 2
entonces nos trasladamos 2 unidades
hacia arriba y otras 2 hacia arriba nos
trasladamos 4 hacia arriba entonces la
respuesta podría ser la ola de ahora la
que es no no están no es no es tan fácil
de asimilar es cuál fue el
desplazamiento en equis y piensen por
ejemplo en la en la ecuación igual a
equis
+ 3 al cuadrado
ok o cambiamos el signo x menos 3 al
cuadrado
si nosotros tenemos esta ecuación que es
lo que vamos a obtener pues en donde
esto se hace cero pues cuando x es igual
a 3 verdad entonces realmente donde pasa
por cero cuando x es igual a 3 entonces
vamos a ver algo así que en x igual a 3
es cero lo cual contra bueno es es anti
intuitivo con el signo verdad si uno
tiene aquí menos tres uno esperaría que
estuviera del otro lado pero no en
realidad estamos trasladando hacia la
derecha cuando le ponemos menos tres si
ahora por ejemplo nosotros tuviera esto
esto sería de igual a x menos tres al
cuadrado entonces si nosotros pensamos
en ye igual a x + 3 al cuadrado en que
el número se anula pues cuando x es
menos 3 entonces andamos como por aquí
ahí es el único punto donde se anula y
entonces esa parábola de igual a equis
+ 3 al cuadrado se ve de esta forma
entonces nosotros estamos pensando en
estas dos parábolas tenemos ya iguala x
+ 3 al cuadrado menos 2 entonces hay que
trasladar menos 2 hacia abajo más o
menos severa
algo así nuestra parábola y por otro
lado tenemos x menos 2 al cuadrado más 2
el vértice primero lo ubicamos en 2 más
o menos como por aquí y luego
trasladamos la parábola hacia arriba 2
unidades
entonces la parábola las dos parábolas
que me interesan son más o menos éstas
más o menos entonces que tanto trasladé
pues aquí estamos en menos tres y aquí
es menos dos entonces en la posición
vertical
me trasladé cuatro unidades verdad
cuatro unidades y eso ya lo habíamos
visto ahora cuanto me trasladé hacia la
derecha a final de cuentas me trasladó
hacia la derecha son tres hasta llegar
al eje y luego otros dos por lo tanto me
voy me moví 5 a la derecha y mi
respuesta final es la incluso si estás
confundido con los traslados a la
izquierda oa la derecha puedes ver que
la diferencia entre tres y menos dos en
5 y de ahí ya lo obtienes aunque yo
esperaría que mejor comprende la parte
geométrica de todas formas nos vemos en
el próximo vídeo